these Christian philosophy debates they
were very important for European
philosophy and European theology and
they're not very well known over here in
the United States and one of the reasons
why is there's kind of a vicious circle
and it's kind of good that I have a
chalkboard I'm going to do this this
lecture imparted lecture and part is
soliciting the answers from you I'm
going to be read French nobody reads
French well just professors Adam should
read French what's on hold out one
person reads French it is kind of a
dying language it's unfortunate but you
know it's it's not as important as
Chinese or Arabic or Spanish these days
so if you want to do scholarship what do
you have to have if you want to research
French authors
how do you do have you have it this is
this class included any any French no
author it included some German well yeah
right somebody just talk about Ratzinger
now benedict the sixteen how did you
redress him he does speak English right
but he didn't write in English somebody
had to provide a translation and without
the translation how many of you read
German few yeah again Americans you know
we're not very we're not very good at
pushing languages so if it's not
available in translation odds are you're
not going to read it and it's not
available in translation that leads to
lack of interest right it is available
in translation now you can be interested
in it you can talk about it with other
people you can publish things on it you
can hold conferences because you're all
on the same page if there's no interest
who's going to translate so there's a
lot of work out there in French and
German especially an Italian and Spanish
that just simply hasn't the translation
really brilliant interesting
groundbreaking philosophical theological
historical you name it there's a lot of
work out there that doesn't get
translated well the reason it doesn't
get that is because of this cycle
because it didn't get translated right
away people assumed it wasn't important
because they assumed it wasn't important
nobody else going to translate it at
least as far as the Christian velocity
debates goes my my emphasis for doing
this was originally as a blown down
scholar lonedell was very involved in
these debates and his early works had
been translated but his later works
counter so I wanted to translate some of
those things and the friend of mine sent
these things to me in the mail and said
why don't you translate this stuff so as
I did it I started finding more and more
works pertaining to these debates and
here in the United States there's sort
of a standard line that you get about
the Christian philosophy debate state
they started in 1931 and they were over
fairly quickly the main people who are
involved were these existentialist homas
it's anjel song and John Laura 10 and
who are there for their protagonists
either rationalist philosophers like
millbrae yay or neo scholastics like
fair nam understand bergen and that's it
that's all there's the story lonedell
got a little bit involved but really not
that involved there's animal story well
the picture is a lot bigger there are
about 50 people involved in these
debates and they went on from 1931 to
about 19 36 when they start compete
around you guys are going to be looking
at resource among theologians later
right hmm we touched on him a little bit
already and water so you talked about on
ready to lubeck I made me spend just a
little bit of time when we were in
Ratzinger ok touching on him yeah he
would be further further along somebody
influenced by the blue block I all ready
to Lou Brock is a young man at the time
of these debates he's sort of sounding
off with the biryani so by the time that
he's actually writing about it and
summarizing it we think the debates are
over but so from 1931 to 1936 you have
about 50 different people weighing in I
brought along a few crops you might say
be careful with these are very old this
is blown dells open them to the
philosophy catholique still not
translated probably not to be translated
for a while almost people decide they
want to do it and this was this is a you
know all book that you wrote in 1932 it
published on
the topic most of the English language
scholarship hasn't read this so I'll
pass this around this was actually the
second this is the account of meetings
of the second session of the associate
80 East homeless philosophers and
theologians got together in Europe
mainly French speaking some Italians
from german-speaking ones and they would
get together and have these days study
and he's called you to see and they had
a theme the first theme was actually
phenomenology natomas were very
interested in that this time it was
Christian philosophy and two of them
made presentations some of them made
impromptu presentations and took up so
much time talking and they argued back
and forth about this so this is a really
live issues a a viable topic for
discussion why would people argue about
this well you know the American context
is different than the French context
here in America let's say you have to
given a number how many denominations do
you think kind of trick questions why it
why is it a trick question it's hard to
count them to be given it right but then
there's all these splits that take plays
were used to a pretty diverse religious
setting it's been that way in America
since the start it's more diverse than
it was previously but that's part of our
cultural landscape in France if you were
Christian you belong to mainly 12
churches you are either
you were reformed protestant are you
gonna here in America although in recent
times the government has been fairly
secularized and some some
administration's but more or less
hostile to religion in in America for
the most part there hasn't been a lot of
controversy about sort of stripping the
public space of the room until the last
maybe 40 years in France that was taking
place from the Revolution and the french
third republic was very sex so secular
that Maurice blowing Bell actually
couldn't get a job for the first two
years because he'd written his doctoral
dissertation in a direction that
ultimately took it towards religion and
so they said well this is theology this
is not philosophy you can't be higher
there was it was a state administration
he wanted to get a job it wasn't like
here where you apply at different places
there was one monolithic state
educational institution and you either
belonged to that or you didn't hear that
the Catholic institutions as well but
they were pretty small so there's this
big push to sort of secularize
philosophy and a lot of religious
philosophers themselves bought into this
in part because if you want to get a job
you had to be able to communicate with
those who were not religious and if hurt
because they have different conceptions
of philosophy one of the things that
comes out of this debate that's very
clear as there's no one single
conception
and the conception of philosophy that
you have is really going to have a huge
effect on your view of whether Christian
philosophy is possible what kind of
relations philosophy would have a
theology and if the ology is even a
rationalist so from the perspective some
of the Philosopher's involved in the
debate just like today some of the
Philosopher's around today what you
would be doing in this classroom would
be pure godly book right some people
would say just purely irrational have
any connection to intellectual culture
you guys are just spinning your wheels
other perspectives take a very different
life so that's probably what they're
fighting about in these debates now one
of the things that I'm curious I've
never actually talked about the debates
with budding theologians I've talked
about them a lot of philosophers and I
think that theologians you have
different preoccupations than
philosophers do we philosophers and to
obsess and quite a bit about improve
ability of things and whether we could
make a strictly rational argument
without making any reference to say
scripture or history of the church yeah
we like to try to make arguments that
even though very often it's not possible
the matters of philosophy religion so
what are the preoccupations that
theologians you're all religion theology
or religion matrixes so what is it that
you who's that that you had 10 editions
how does philosophy fit in why bother
okay society how society does not seem
to be particularly interested in
philosophy yeah that's a good way to put
society on a surface is not interested
in philosophy society in its ground is
conditioned by philosophy because
everybody has a particular philosophical
perspective big issues some of those big
issues are ones that impinge on theology
does God exist many people have decided
that question one way or another and
that's not just a theological question
philosophical question what else would
you care about the flaws why would these
debates have anything to do with your
lives or your profession is you're going
to practice may not for some you're
going to be just a biblical hermeneutics
explicate Scripture i guess the
philosophy influence of language yes
language articulate our play okay yeah
that makes sense
I was actually kind of joking with you
two if you're doing scriptural relatives
his philosophy going to be important for
you well think about some of the big
scripture scholars of the century the
ones who make huge impacts take Bolton
for example you guys have studied did
you get studied yet not really us all
that's in order to understand fault when
you have to read Heidegger because
Baldwin was influenced by haider in
order to understand what movie should
inspire you focused on kid rotzinger and
then oh we read you know we have lots of
very much philosopher yeah weird some
african theology okay and ended up with
nicola / okay most recently so what
would you it'd be silly to ask what
would you have to read in order to
understand ratzinger fully because he's
read the entire corpus in philosophy and
engaged just about everybody is he
writes a lot as a matter of fact he's
got an interesting book out where he
dialogues with your github Ramona's
nature of reason and whether it has to
be purely secular whether religion has a
role in society so theologians are tied
in with molasses seems to me them you
know if I could just gotta jump in but
what why we would one reason we would be
interested in is the relation between
faith and reason yeah yeah and if you
think about that use a chalkboard I can
get more chocolates
we often counterpoise these to each
other as if there are two separate
domains right there's the main of faith
and there you have to know things
through revealed truth you know
scripture those who weren't around and
that scripture was written you know
presumably through the actual Christ
event seeing the guy spending time with
him the influence behind and then
there's reason and reason is something
purely natural you don't need faith at
all in order to make it work but what is
this this is a particular philosophical
perspective visible it's also a
particular theological perspective and
maybe one that a lot of people assume
and in our society sort of the de facto
starting point but if you're really
doing good philosophy or good theology
do you make a lot of assumptions like
that without stalling them out or
without arguing for them seeing whether
they're actually the case